Morning everyone.
Can you hear me on Zoom?
All right.
Hope Twitch can hear me, too.
So,
did anybody do anything exciting this
weekend?
Fortnite tournament, studying for the
midterm.
All very exciting.
All right.
Time to get started, I think. So, today
is our pause for breath day on the
schedule.
Which is um
a day where we can use to catch up on
anything that we didn't have time for in
the previous
12 lectures. Um
So, we didn't cover everything that I
wanted to cover last time pertaining to
replication techniques, primary backup
replication, and chain replication. So,
I want to wrap that up.
Then I want to
spend a little time. Uh
And we'll do a quiz question and stuff.
And then I want to spend a little time
on questions that people asked on the
start of course survey that I said that
I would answer at some point.
Uh and then
we'll open it up to questions that
people have. Midterm review, if you
want.
And um
uh
And then if we if nobody has any
questions, we can end early.
Folks are saying there's audio problems.
Um
that's too bad.
I'm not getting any um
notification from Zoom that my internet
is is unstable. So hopefully it'll
improve.
I'll go
complain to my husband if he's like
streaming Tekken right now.
All right.
So
Let's quickly recap what we said before
about
about replication techniques.
Yeah, my husband plays Tekken. He plays
competitively.
He he would tell you that he's terrible,
but um
I think he's pretty good.
So
Last time we talked about primary backup
replication. Let's quickly review what
that is.
So the idea is that there's a
primary node that clients interact with.
When clients want to do a right
they send it to the primary
and then there's some number of backups.
Where when the primary gets a right
uh
it then broadcasts that to the backups.
And the backups acknowledge the primary.
And this is the commit point here.
Which is the point at which the right
can have been said to happen.
And that's also the point at which the
primary delivers the right to itself and
then acknowledges the client.
So it's only at this point that the
client knows that the right has taken
effect.
So, that's the right path.
And for the read path,
client just talks to the primary.
So, that's primary backup. Uh it takes
how many messages to hear back when you
do a write? Uh one message here and then
the maximum length of whichever one of
these uh
plus the maximum of whichever one of
these um plus uh
one more here. So, four messages in this
round trip.
Uh
only two messages for reads.
So, um
primary backup has some problems. Uh one
of the problems is that
the primary node has to handle
everything.
Uh which doesn't do anything uh
to um
to improve uh it doesn't do anything to
take any of the burden off the primary,
which was one of the goals of doing
replication in the first place. So,
uh chain replication
was invented.
In chain replication,
you've got
a head node, we'll call it H, and a tail
node,
and some number of nodes in the middle.
When the primary does a write, it writes
to the head.
The head passes that on to the next node
in the chain and so on to the tail.
And the tail acknowledges the client.
So, how many messages will that take?
Well, it'll take however many
replicas there are plus one.
Uh so, that's a number that's going to
grow linearly with the number of
replicas that there are.
So it's a potentially long wait if you
have a lot of replicas.
And then for reads
Excuse me, not that. Reads go to the
tail. That's the whole point.
So reads go to the tail.
And the tail handles all the reads. So
it's a way to split up the work
between the
the head and the tail. The head doesn't
have to do any acknowledgement of the
client. So it's fewer messages for the
head to have to send.
So
potentially the throughput is better.
Under what circumstances are is the
throughput going to be better? Well, the
chain replication people
had some discussion of this in their
paper and I actually want to show you
some figures from the chain replication
paper that that help illustrate this. So
um
So let me find the the window with the
chain replication paper one second.
So this paper was published in 2004.
It's called chain replication for
supporting high throughput and
availability.
Um
And let me share it with you.
Okay, so the
there's a lot to read here but the
particular part that I want to show you
is a figure that appears in the
evaluation.
Um
So,
here it is.
So, this is a figure um
showing request throughput.
Uh so, if we look at um So, there's two
three different figures here. If we took
it If we look at the one on the left, so
this this number T here um is the number
of replicas that there are.
So, in this case, there are just uh two
replicas for figure 4A
Um so, there's several different lines
in this figure. Let's talk about what
they are. Uh the bottom one here uh and
I'll I'll try to make this a little
bigger so it's more readable actually.
Um
Uh so, the bottom line, these um uh
these things that look like stars, uh
this is what the behavior of primary
backup replication is, which is what
they're comparing chain replication
with.
Uh this one with pluses uh
is weak replication, and by that they
mean uh
uh uh a a replication strategy where
clients can talk to any randomly
selected replica. So, note that weak
replication doesn't actually offer the
same strong consistency guarantee uh
that either chain replication or primary
backup replication do.
And then chain replication is this curve
here with the X's.
Um Now, notice the shape of the curve.
Um So, the shape of the curve is
interesting. Um So, notice that with um
with either weak replication or primary
backup replication, uh the throughput
decreases over time. The throughput's a
lot higher for the weak replication
actually, um but that's because with
weak replication
uh
uh clients can talk to any replica, and
also there's not the strong consistency
guarantee.
Uh so, there isn't any kind of um uh
contention on who's talking to a head or
a tail since any replica uh or since any
client can talk to any replica.
Um
for for chain replication, notice that
there's this interesting shape to this
curve here. Uh where
if 0% of the of the messages that are
hitting
the the um
the storage system are updates as
opposed to just queries as opposed to
you know, what's the value of X. Um
then the curve exactly matches that of
primary backup replication. And the same
is true up here. Once you get to 50%
updates, um
chain replication also behaves the same
as primary backup replication. The point
at which chain replication has the
biggest advantage over primary backup
replication is right about here in the
curve where they say 10 to 15% of the
requests are updates. Um so
to go back to our to our picture here,
uh
when 10 to 15%
of the requests are rights,
uh which are these up here, uh as
opposed to reads,
uh that's when chain replication's
throughput has the best has the biggest
improvement over primary backup.
Why do you think that's true? Why is it
the case that when 10 to 15% of the of
the updates are
uh
are rights, that's when chain
replication does the best compared to
primary backup. But when it's either 0%
or or 50% or more, uh they perform about
the same.
So here's that figure again from the
paper.
And for the person who asked about the
format of the midterm, uh there have
been a couple of announcements in the
announcements channel on our Slack.
Uh
T is the number of replicas.
So uh somebody just asked what T means.
So uh
for this one where T equals two, there's
just two replicas. Uh for these other
ones where T equals three and T equals
10, that's three and 10 replicas
uh
respectively. So notice that like so for
weak replication for instance, notice
that its throughput just gets higher and
higher when there are more replicas.
Uh which would make sense because uh
for weak rep replication uh
clients can just talk to any replica and
there's no guarantee that they're going
to be getting the most up-to-date
information. Uh so if you have 10
replicas and the requests and it's the
same number of requests spread out among
10 replicas instead of two or three, um
then uh obviously you can you can uh
handle more requests uh in the same
amount of time.
So, again, the question was um
this 10 to this 10 to 15% number uh
which is about what it looks like to me,
the point where there's a little bump in
this curve uh
for uh
for chain replication, the point at
which chain replication does the best
compared with primary backup
replication.
So,
why would that be better at that point?
my understanding of the situation is
that
writes take longer than reads to
process. So, if you were to split up the
the the load equally between writes and
reads, then primary backup replication
and chain replication would perform
about the same, and indeed, that's what
these figures more or less bear out.
Uh so, by splitting So, what chain
replication does, right, is split things
up equally uh between the head and the
tail. Uh so, the tail
um handles reads, the head handles
writes. Um
but the head never actually has to
acknowledge the client. All the head has
to do is is handle these write requests.
So, it turns out that it's not actually
an even balance uh if we split up
equally between uh like if we give 50%
writes and 50% reads, it turns out that
that's not fair um
uh because writes take longer to
process. So, in that case, um
uh there isn't actually any advantage of
chain replication over over primary
backup replication. Likewise, if all the
requests are are reads,
then all the requests go to the tail
anyway. So, that's not an advantage over
primary backup replication because
then there's still just one process
handling everything.
Uh so, this 10 to 15% seems to be a sort
of magic number. So, if you have if
you're if your workload is 10 to 15%
writes,
um
then that's about the mix of writes
versus reads that you want in order to
get an advantage out of chain
replication. Uh and that seems to be
true at least in the experiments that
they did.
Uh
that seems to be more or less true, um
regardless of whether they had two
replicas or three replicas or 10
replicas, the peak of that chain
replication curve uh for uh in in peak
in terms of advantage over primary
backup replication seems to be about the
same.
So, a lot of people are complaining
about the audio quality um both on
Twitch and Zoom. Um so, actually So, my
husband isn't really streaming Tekken
right now, but let me just check in the
other room to see if there's anything
going on. Just a second.
All right, sorry about that. Um yeah, I
don't know what it is. My daughter's
watching Sesame Street videos. That's
usually not such a bandwidth hog.
Okay. So, um,
this is the main thing I wanted to say
about chain replication versus primary
backup replication. So, um, you can go
and read the paper yourself if you want
to. Um, uh,
but, um,
but the, um,
uh, the the main thing I want to point
out here is that, uh,
uh, chain replication provides an
advantage over primary backup
replication in this certain specific
situation, uh, where, um, where you have
maybe about 10 to 15% of rights. It
turns out that that's actually a pretty
common number,
uh, for typical applications to be maybe
10 to 15% rights and 85-90% reads.
Okay. So,
there's another aspect of these
replication strategies that we didn't
really talk about last time.
Uh, and so, I want to get to that today.
So,
the thing that we didn't talk about,
which some people did ask about,
um, is
how you deal with failure.
So, let's talk about this, um,
so,
let's let's say that it's it's primary
backup.
So, you have a primary and a couple of
backups.
So, the client has to know
who to talk to, right? Uh, they have to
know to talk to the the primary.
And if the primary were to fail,
and in that case, somebody else would
have to take over as the primary, then
somebody would have to be in charge of
telling the client that
there's a new primary.
So,
in that case, who's going to be in
charge of of of telling the client what
to do?
Well, clients have to know who to
contact. So, what you might have is
actually some sort of proxy here.
Uh who the clients contact and then it's
the proxy's job to pass on traffic uh
to to these replicas. And it's also the
proxy's job to know who is the given
um
who who is the who is the primary at any
given moment.
Um and then that proxy, if it were chain
replication, the proxy also has to know
who the tail is. They have to know who
the head and the tail is.
And then of course the replicas
themselves have to know who's who,
right? Um so, if it's chain replication,
and you have say three replicas,
it's pretty important that
the chain knows what the next member of
the chain that each each member of the
chain knows what the next member of the
chain is, right? Um and it's important
that they agree on that, right? Because
it would be pretty bad if um the head
thought that this machine was the next
uh or or it'd be pretty bad if if if if
I thought that one machine was the head
and somebody else thought a different
machine was the head. Uh and then that
would be um uh
that would that would that would wreak
havoc. So, the replicas have to know
who's who. The client has to know who to
contact. And so, um
there there has to be ultimately the
presence of of some kind of coordinator
node whose job it is to know who all the
replicas are
and what role they're playing at a given
time and and keep everybody else
informed of those roles.
So this coordinator,
um,
which maybe I'll put over here.
So the coordinator's job could be solely
to tell replicas, "You're the head now."
Or "You're the tail."
Uh, and perhaps to tell clients
so-and-so is the head.
And to tell other replicas in the node,
"By the replicas or tell other nodes, by
the way, this replica is the head and
this replica is the tail."
Uh, the coordinator also has to be able
to detect failures. Uh, and when a
replica does fail,
it's the coordinator's job to tell
everybody else what that new
configuration is going to be.
Okay, so for chain replication, uh, for
example, if we have these three
replicas,
the coordinator's job is to know who's
who.
Um,
it's to detect failures and handle them.
Um, and it's to tell clients about who's
the head and who's the tail.
Um, so maybe, you know, if this is if
this here is, um,
machine one and this is machine two and
this is machine three,
um,
then
the coordinator is going to have some
state like
head is M1,
B is M2,
T is M3.
By the way, uh, there's an assumption
here that not all of the replicas will
fail.
So if you have N replicas, then there's
an assumption that at most N minus one
will fail.
And there's also an assumption that you
can somehow tell when a replica has
failed. Um, so this is a somewhat more
forgiving fault model than the crash
model that we talked about before.
Before, we said that a replica could
crash by just stopping sending and
receiving messages. But, we didn't say
that it was going to announce to
everybody, "I'm crashing now."
Um
So, we have to be able to We We We just
said that a process fails by halting,
you know, it's not sending or receiving
messages.
But, we don't necessarily know that a
crashed process has crashed, right?
Maybe it's still running,
um but all the messages are being lost
or maybe if you're if you're not if
you're assuming no message loss, maybe
the messages are just slow.
Um So, for chain replication,
uh
there's actually an assumption that
processes can crash and that you can
tell that they've crashed.
Um
Is this a realistic assumption? Well,
yes and no.
So,
maybe you can ask every process to
periodically send you a message saying,
"I'm alive."
And then, if you miss a few of those
messages in a row, then you declare it
to be dead, right?
So, sometimes you're going to be wrong.
Sometimes it might still be alive, but
the I'm alive messages got dropped or
delayed. So, from time to time you might
declare a machine dead when it really
isn't.
Um and if you find that this happens
often, you might want to increase your
timeout length.
And failure detection is its own whole
deep topic that we could spend time on
if we want to. But, the the short
version is that perfect failure
detection is impossible. So, at least
it's an impossible in an asynchronous
distributed system. So, every now and
then, you're going to be declaring a
machine to be dead even though it's not
actually dead.
Anyway,
we're going to assume that we can detect
failures.
So, real quick, in chain replication,
let's say that the head process that
fails. And let's say that the
coordinator sees that it fails.
Uh
So, somebody just asked in chat, "What's
the point of the coordinator?" Um
So, it's the coordinator's job to know
who's who, right?
To detect failures of these replicas,
and to tell clients who the head and
tail are in chain replication, for
instance. In the case of primary backup,
it would be the coordinator's role to
tell clients uh who the primary is, cuz
the client only interacts with the
primary in that case.
So,
what does the coordinator do if the head
process fails and the coordinator sees
that it fails? Any guesses?
Now, let's just say So, somebody just
asked, "Is the coordinator the same as
the proxy?" So, proxy here was an
example of if you wanted to uh
Uh yeah, forget about this.
Let's just say that the coordinator is
something that's internal to this system
here, and the coordinator's job is to
know who all these replicas are,
um and the client interacts with the
head, but periodically, if the um if the
head were to fail,
then um
the coordinator is going to have to tell
the client who to interact with now.
This proxy was sort of an attempt to to
to ensure that the client would already
be always be interacting with the same
replica, um but that doesn't really work
because we don't have any guarantee that
the proxy would be any more robust to
failure than the primary would.
Yeah, so
just establishes another backup process
as the head. Good answer. So, So if the
if the head were to fail
in chain replication, then the
coordinator just has to take the head
process out of the chain, and it just
makes the successor to it the new head
to the chain.
And then of course it has to tell
clients who the new head is.
Um similarly, when a tail fails, uh the
coordinator just removes the tail
process from the chain and makes its
predecessor the new tail.
And then it has to tell clients who the
new tail is. So in this case, because we
only had three, if the head and the tail
both died,
then now this process is both the head
and the tail. So now we've we've
reverted to a scenario where not only do
we uh do we have any sort of throughput
improvement, but we don't even have any
fault tolerance either. So we better
bring up a couple of more uh replicas.
Um what about when a middle node fails?
Well, then the predecessor and the
successor had to have to be hooked up to
one another. No need to tell clients
anything.
So the really important question now
that a bunch of you have been asking is
this.
What if the coordinator fails?
And by the way,
although I've been talking about chain
replication here in primary backup,
there also has to be a coordinator to
handle primary failures and backup
failures and making sure the client
knows who the primary is. So what if the
coordinator fails?
What can we do to be more tolerant of
coordinator failures?
Anyone know?
Or have a guess?
Well,
the whole point of having this
replicated storage system here, or part
of the point anyway, of having this
replicated storage system was fault
tolerance, right?
So,
we have some data. We have the value of
X, right?
Which is being replicated in these
different places largely for reasons of
fault tolerance, perhaps also for
reasons of throughput in the case of of
of chain replication. Uh but we have
multiple copies.
So,
you could also imagine having a bunch of
copies of the coordinator.
Have a bunch of coordinators.
Which you hope fail independently.
But then those coordinators have to be
consistent with each other.
So, how do you keep them consistent with
each other? Well, are you going to
implement primary backup or chain
replication among those coordinators as
well?
And then do you have to have a
coordinator for that primary backup or
chain replication system and then so on
forever?
So, this is actually the perfect lead-in
to our next big topic in this course, uh
which is consensus.
And we're going to save our discussion
of consensus uh until after the midterm.
Uh we're not going to talk about it
today. Uh but
if you look at the chain replication
paper, the first thing they say, which
is really funny actually, is they say,
"Well, we assume the coordinator doesn't
fail."
Uh which we know is an unrealistic
assumption. Um and they then admit that
that's an unrealistic assumption. And
then they explain that in the actual
reference implementation that they did
build, they have instead of one
coordinator process, they have a small
group of coordinator processes that are
among themselves running a consensus
protocol to make sure that they agree
with one another and essentially behave
as though they're one process.
So, I find it really interesting and a
little bit sobering, too, that if we
want to have
consistency, if we cuz the remember that
the whole point of both chain
replication and primary backup
replication was to provide strong
consistency between replicas.
If we want to have strong consistency
between replicas,
which is what these replication
protocols give you,
and we also want to be tolerant of
faults,
which was probably the reason why we
were doing replication in the first
place, then ultimately we end up being
reliant on a consensus protocol.
And that should give you pause because
consensus is hard and expensive. So,
that's one reason not to have strong
consistency, perhaps. If you can get
away with a weaker consistency
guarantee, like causal consistency, then
maybe you should.
But there are times when you really do
need consensus, and there are times when
you really do need strong consistency.
Uh, so we're going to get into that
after the midterm, uh, starting on
Friday.
Um,
but
for now, um,
uh, this is just a a thought to carry
with you that ultimately, even if you
have, um, this primary backup or a chain
replication approach, like primary
backup is it's not too sophisticated,
right? You just have a primary and some
backups, but somebody has to be in
charge if you're if if failure is a
thing, then somebody has to be in charge
of knowing who the primary and who the
backups are at any given time. And that
problem boils down to consensus.
So, we end up being uh being reliant on
consensus even in this fairly
unsophisticated situation.
All right.
Questions about any of that?
I'm scrolling back through chat here to
see uh what questions were asked.
Yeah, so one suggestion for this problem
of coordinator failure in chat was uh
uh assign one of the backups uh as a
leader via some election algorithm. So,
this problem of leader election also
boils down to the problem of consensus.
Sorry about the bad quality, everyone.
All right.
So,
for fun,
I thought that we would
uh look at some questions that folks
asked me on the start of course survey.
So, um
These were the questions that people
submitted. About 60 people filled out
the startup course survey,
um and this question was optional, um
about do you have any questions for me?
Um
There were There were 15 responses to
this question, um
and I haven't actually read them all.
Um Oh, here's a great question. Before I
get to this, uh here's a great question
in in uh
uh in chat. Um are the coordinators
distributed even though they're grouped
to act like a single coordinator? So,
that's a great question, right? So,
you really want you you you really hope
that not all of these coordinator
processes that are supposed to act like
a single coordinator, you you really
hope that they don't all fail, right? Um
cuz that would be really bad. You want
at least one of them to be alive at any
given time.
So, um certainly if they're all, you
know, in one, let's say, one data
center, then there if that whole data
center fails, if it gets hit by a
tornado, then um
the then that's bad news for you, right?
Um but practically speaking,
it's going to be harder to do consensus
the more physically distributed they
are, right? Meaning it'll be slower,
it'll be more susceptible to to message
loss, and so on. So, um
so so you might
you you really probably wouldn't do
that. Um
you would probably have them in one
place and just try to do your best to
ensure that that that failures are
independent enough.
Um the This isn't really I mean, we we
talk about thing about failures being
independent in distributed systems, but
failures are rarely entirely
independent. Uh so,
uh in in in reality, you know, we just
kind of do our best, uh
and it if if two machines are in the
same data center, we can't really be
said that they fail We can't really say
that they fail independently, right? Um
uh
machines that are in different data
centers on different sides of the world
are more independent. Um but I mean,
they're also on the same planet, right?
Um
are are we going to start have to locate
data centers on Mars in order to ensure
independence? So, and it depends what
you call independent, right?
Um and you have to you have to come up
with some definition of independent
failure that's uh
that's practical for your purposes.
Okay, so let's see what people asked
here. And I I haven't actually scrolled
through all of these yet myself. So, um
so let's see. What drew you to UCSC?
Uh so
I was working at Intel Labs before I
came to UCSC. I was in a group called
the Parallel Computing Lab. Uh it's
really cool group. Um They do a lot of
work that's uh
uh
kind of they have a lot of I'll say they
have a lot of architecture experts there
uh who know a ton about particular uh
parallel computing architectures. Uh
they also have a lot of machine learning
experts there. Um and I spent almost 4
years working there.
Uh yeah, Sa Sa heat works at Intel as
well. So, um um
so he's um
he's a fan. Um
So, um
uh it's a great organization. Uh for me,
uh I actually found that I wanted to do
a different kind of research. And uh
uh there was a a job opening here at
UCSC. Uh it was actually for distributed
systems, which I wasn't getting to do
too much of. Uh and I was kind of my
identity as a researcher was changing. I
was becoming more of a distributed
systems person. Uh and I decided that
that's what I wanted to do. And
I applied and and was lucky lucky enough
to get the job. This was
in Santa Clara.
Uh so, um somebody just asked which
which Intel location. It was Santa Clara
uh SC12 for those of you who know the
Intel buildings.
Um,
but, um, Intel's a good place to work.
Um, they're very family-friendly, I
noticed. Um,
uh, so I my my daughter was born while I
was working there, and they're really
supportive employer. Um, uh,
so he probably knows that, too. Um,
and, um,
uh, yeah, they're still a really really
wonderful group of people here. It's
just that my my interests started to
diverge a little bit from uh, what my
group was doing.
Um,
next question. Um, how is it being a
woman in CS? Uh,
well, you have to deal with a lot of
people asking you, uh, how is it being a
woman in CS?
Uh, next question. Um,
what kind of programming languages are
well suited for this kind of project?
You listed some that past students have
used, but no recommendations or
cautions. Uh,
if you don't want to recommend
specifics, can you mention features of
languages that might prove helpful?
Um,
so, it's probably a little late for me
to be giving anybody advice about, um,
what language to use, uh, for the group
project.
But, um,
it's, um,
honestly, so so Python is a really safe
choice. Um, Go has been a good choice.
Um,
Java is a is a good choice. Um,
uh,
um,
so, my
my research group and I started working
on a reference implementation of the
course project in Haskell, and, um, I
didn't get very far, and now, like, two
of my grad students are working on it
with me. So, um, you can take what you
want away from that. Um,
uh, probably, um, it would be better if,
um,
if I were a better Haskell programmer.
Um
yeah.
Um yeah, I don't know. Um so, I I I
honestly wouldn't necessarily recommend
that you write C for the course project
um
because it's uh
it it's just unnecessarily low-level for
the kinds of
uh for the kind of problem that we're
asking you to solve. Um and there's a
similar project in uh
in CSE 130
which um which does require writing C um
but
you know, it's like
that's a project which has different
goals. So, the the the concerns that we
have in this project are totally
different. Um somebody asked about
JavaScript. So, JavaScript is uh
JavaScript can be a good choice. Some
people use Node last year. Um uh I think
it has some
uh
I I yeah, I think it could work. Uh
honestly though, like my answer to this
question and you know, you might be
surprised to hear programming languages
researcher say this, but um the best
language to use is the language that you
and your team like and that you feel
motivated and comfortable writing. So,
and and
this is you know, if if that's if that's
Java, then great. If that's Python,
great. If that's Go, great. If that's
JavaScript, great. If it's Haskell,
great. Um and indeed, um it is more
about frameworks and libraries and you
know, I I
I
I don't know how anybody writes um
let's say C++ out of uh
like an institutional context where
there's some uh
um
uh
institution-specific package management
um because uh the package management uh
um just out in out in the wild world is
is is kind of a nightmare. Um
So,
um yeah, you can write REST APIs in
Haskell. You should check out the
servant library. It's really neat.
Um,
okay, so um, on to the next question.
Favorite XKCD comic? You know, I
actually went back and looked at them
last night to try to figure out what my
favorite was.
Um,
uh, and I mean, I'm still partial to um,
I think it's number 150. Um, uh,
apartment full of of um, playpen balls.
Um, but I feel like if I were as a
responsible adult, I should probably say
that it's one of the ones about climate
change.
Um, is this class still a group project
class? Obviously, yes.
Um,
what challenges you are facing with this
class that we as students can help with?
You know, I'm just really touched that
somebody asked this question.
Uh, cuz
it's it I I'm just really impressed by
the the the students in this class have
a level of maturity where they care
about
uh,
about my uh,
experience teaching the class. And so,
you know, I I I I don't know. I mean, I
think you're doing the right thing by
uh, by just continuing to participate
actively.
What is your favorite book? Um, this is
a hard one.
Um,
so
uh,
a a
a novel that I uh,
or a series of novels that I really
enjoyed recently uh,
were the Earthsea uh, books by Octavia
Butler.
Um, which uh,
uh,
which I I could would be happy to point
you to.
Um, so it's it's she writes a lot of
books that are sort of like
post-apocalyptic uh, science fiction.
Um, and I'm a fan. Or she did. She's no
longer with us.
Some people are making jokes about
scheme in but I I should say that that
PLT Scheme was my first programming
language and and PLT Scheme is now known
as Racket and it's still probably my
favorite programming language. So,
yeah.
All right.
Why are you so awesome?
Um
Wow, thank you.
Uh next question. Will there be there be
problems with having this course in an
online platform? Of course there'll be
problems. Um there are problems today.
Um but we're doing the best we can.
Job prospects. Obviously, job prospects
are not what they were before COVID-19,
but they're still pretty good compared
to a lot of fields.
Um
Are companies looking for people to work
on distributed systems? Absolutely.
Yeah. So, and and
in fact,
um
a lot of systems are distributed systems
that you might not expect are. So, I'm
hoping that what you learn in this class
will end up be relevant to a lot of jobs
that you might have not ever thought
were
uh
were even necessarily about distributed
systems.
Um
Next question. At some point, either
directly or with the class, can you
share with us your experience of getting
into academia? So, I moved back and
forth between academia and industry. So,
I I did undergrad. I then um
uh I worked in industry for a few years.
Uh I worked for some uh for a terrible
startup that failed and then I worked
for um
a large publishing company. Then I went
to grad school.
Uh and I did some different kinds of
internships when I was in grad school.
Um some more academic than others.
Then I worked at Intel Labs, uh which
was an industry research job, uh and and
then I came here to USC.
Um so, I've been bouncing back and
forth.
And um I think in computer science it's
much easier to do that bouncing back and
forth than it is to do than it is in a
lot of fields.
Um,
I think that academia is an option
that's under explored by a lot of
computer science uh
undergrads.
Uh so,
you might not think that it's an option
for you for whatever reason, but I you
know, I urge you to reconsider.
Um,
how distributed systems is relevant in
the industry, I hope that this uh will
be answered especially by our guest
speakers.
Um,
what sorts of machine learning and deep
learning applications exist in
distributed systems? Um so, there's
quite a lot. Um so, just to throw out an
example that has to do with what we
talked about today, um so, this question
about like
you have a coordinator, what if the
coordinator fails? Um,
or you need to to um elect a leader.
Um well, you might want to try to pick
one that's unlikely to fail, right? And
that could potentially be a machine
learning problem.
Um just to throw something out there. Um
but, there's a whole conference called
SysML that's about um
um applications of systems to to machine
learning and applications of machine
learning to systems, uh which I'd
recommend uh you check out if you're
interested in this. And this is all
Google ever does, right? Uh Google turns
uh machine learning problems into
systems problems at a massive scale. So,
um it I mean, it's it like I I can't
even scratch the surface of how to
answer this question, um
but um
but it's
um
it's it's uh
there's an enormous uh
um
there's an enormous number of
applications that marry machine learning
with distributed systems.
Um and hopefully this last question
about jobs uh has already been answered
as well. Okay, so that's it for the
start of course survey questions. Thanks
for everybody who who submitted
questions.
Um
in the time left, um who has questions
that uh
um that I can help answer for exam
review or anything else?
And I'm open to answering questions
either on Twitch or on Slack.
And if nobody asks any, then we'll go
home early.
Oh, right. We already are at home.
We'll end the the meeting early.
Ah, how much about replication do we
need to know for the mid
Um
yeah, so the stuff that I talked about
today about coordinator failure and so
on, that won't be on the midterm.
Oh, somebody just asked, "What about the
quiz question for today?" Sure enough, I
had a quiz question set up for today and
I didn't didn't give it to you. So,
let's do that.
Here is today's quiz question.
And the form should already be open.
Yeah.
I will share the link.
Thanks for reminding me.
Okay.
So while people are
answering that, um
let me try to answer this question about
about replication um
for the midterm. So
uh
on the midterm you you you won't have to
know anything about what what we talked
about today about like what if the head
node fails, what if the tail node fails,
what if the what if the middle node
fails, what if the coordinator fails,
that sort of stuff. Um instead uh there
will be questions uh that are um
actually uh about what what is primary
backup, what is chain replication um
just kind of at a high level.
Um so
if you're caught up in terms of last
lecture, then you should be in good
shape.
How many questions will there be? Um so
this was answered in the announcement uh
about the exam. Um I think I said there
will be about 15 questions.
Yes.
You will not have to draw and upload
anything for the midterm. Good question.
So um
yeah, so on a typical exam that I would
give in person, um it would be um there
would be some drawing involved. I would
ask people to draw pictures.
Um
so
I spend a whole lot of time in this
class drawing pictures like this,
obviously. So, um
uh
I like to ask students to do that, too.
But, the logistics of it is just too
hard to to handle for a a midterm length
exam. On the final, we may ask you to
draw and upload something, and we we
will still have to work out the
logistics of that. But, on the midterm,
we will not ask you to draw any
pictures.
Um it's all going to be um
uh
questions that you answer uh with uh one
or two sentences.
Um
uh
and um
or let's see. I think some of them are
answered in one to two sentences. Some
of them Some of them are like answered
in two to four sentences.
There's a question
on Twitch.
What's your take on free and open-source
software
and the big push by universities by UCSC
to use platforms like Zoom and ProctorU?
So, it's been Zoom has It's been
interesting how ubiquitous Zoom has been
across higher education. Um like this is
not just UCSC.
Uh
almost every uh an educator that I know
uh has been um
uh has been using Zoom.
And it's not just higher education,
either. Uh
so, um
yeah, uh like it or not, um Zoom seems
to seems to have cornered uh this part
of the market.
So, I don't love Zoom.
Uh
and indeed
students in this class have the option
of not using Zoom, right? Um they have
the option of of of just watching on
Twitch.
Um
Now,
there have been a lot of privacy
complaints about Zoom, um but I'm not
sure that most of the alternatives are
much better.
Uh so, um
it now that that isn't to say that we
should just resign ourselves to software
that's horribly insecure and and privacy
invading, um but um
but I but I don't necessarily have a
better solution in mind.
Um
uh
ProctorU, uh
I think is pretty creepy and I'm not
alone in thinking that and a lot of my
colleagues refuse to use it and I refuse
to use it as well.
I will also say that in terms of um
uh like commitment to using free and
open source software,
um
there's um and it's it's
so, it depends, right? If if if you
don't want to use uh anything but free
and open source software, uh well, right
now you're using Slack, right? If you're
in my class, uh
which isn't free and open source, right?
Um or you and and neither is is is
Twitch. So, the only difference is that
they happen to be running on somebody
else's computer instead of yours.
Um so, um
if if the issue is is uh
installing proprietary software on your
own machine, um then
uh you can avoid doing that, but I I
hardly think that that's much of a
meaningful distinction.
Um
so,
I I I have resigned myself to using a
fair amount of proprietary software for
certain aspects of doing my job. Um
and no, uh
maybe uh maybe that means that I'm
morally compromised. I don't know.
Uh somebody asked me to go over the
answer to the quiz question.
Um let's see.
Has everybody who was going to answer
the quiz done so?
Um
I'm not sure.
Yeah, I'm going to give it a little more
time to see if anybody else wants to
answer the quiz.
But honestly, if you want to know the
answer to the quiz question, just go
back and watch this lecture.
Other questions? Questions about the
exam?
Um one question is will the midterm
questions be in similar style to the
quick quiz questions? Okay, so um
I yeah, I guess so. Um
So
for the midterm um
unlike the quiz questions uh
we actually grade you on the content of
your answer.
So um
I'm hoping that people will put a little
bit uh more effort into how they answer
the questions.
Um
and um so so we typically ask you to to
write, you know, anywhere like one to
two or two to four sentences and we'll
specify, you know, how long of an answer
we expect for the for the midterm
questions.
Uh
but the the flavor of the questions will
be similar. Uh
some of the questions will be a little
uh
will will perhaps take a little bit
longer to understand, right? Because um
we'll ask you to for example look at a
diagram and then answer questions about
the diagram. Uh so that'll take a little
bit longer to to to uh to kind of take
in the question and understand what it's
asking.
Uh
There's a question uh
for the algorithms should we just know
how to apply it and understand how it
work? Um
I'm
uh I'm not sure I
I understand exactly what you're asking
here. Um as opposed to what?
So if you're just wondering what's going
to be covered, um it's going to be
everything from the lectures uh so far.
So uh you can go back and look at the
schedule.
Uh which I could bring up right now.
So, anything from
the first
uh
first 12 lectures
is fair game for the exam.
Yeah, I I I I wouldn't say the the the
main difference from
uh the the midterms that I do
uh
in person on paper is that So, on on
those midterms, there were typically
more questions and more of the questions
would be, let's say, multiple-choice and
fill-in-the- blank. So, I opted this
time to have fewer questions and have
more of them be um like uh
uh short short essay questions. I don't
like the word essay question because
that implies that you have to write
something long when I'm really just
talking about a couple of sentences. But
I don't know a better word. A short
essay question, I guess. And then also
on a typical exam, we'd ask people to
draw diagrams, and we're not doing that
this time. So, yeah, hopefully it won't
be that different.
Okay.
So, it doesn't look like there's too
many more questions. Uh oh wait,
somebody's ask asking a question. I'll
wait for that.
Oh, I guess not.
All right.
In that case, I think we're going to end
a little bit early.
Good luck on the midterm on Wednesday.
Uh I won't be streaming on Wednesday.
And then uh we'll see you
on Friday for class again. Thanks.